[Music]
many leaders see
testing as the way out of this dark and
sporadic tunnel of coronavirus lockdowns
the thinking being that if you can catch
someone before they spread the virus
and you can slow and even stop the
pandemic
in austria the government is planning a
mass testing campaign
here a bike courier drops off tests at
apartments in vienna
he'll be back in the evening to collect
the samples to be tested
but not every test is created equal and
the timing of tests is also crucial
getting to someone before they're
infectious can make or break
a contact tracing campaign
a mass testing program in northern italy
has identified over 3 000
coronavirus cases now many of those
people had no idea that they had covered
19.
testing can clearly be a powerful tool
for combating the spread of the virus
but what tests you do and where is key
we report from a hospital in berlin
a coronavirus test to make sure this
patient's not infected
ahead of her operation in a few days
time
it doesn't hurt exactly but it's very
unpleasant it feels like the swab is
poking around in your brain
the test is obligatory to protect other
patients and staff at hospitals like
this one in berlin
but many people in germany would like
the chance to be tested more regularly
it would be good if we could use the
tests to make things like traveling
easier
to be a bit safer
that doesn't look likely any time soon
with testing capacity at its limits the
government is trying to ease the
pressure on overworked labs
even some hospitals are shifting away
from the more reliable pcr tests instead
using the faster cheaper antigen tests
to check their staff for the virus
the advantage of rapid tests is that we
get a result within 30 minutes
it's relatively reliable and a
relatively easy testing system
but on the other hand the disadvantage
is that we know the rapid tests are
slightly less sensitive to the virus
the pcr test is the gold standard it's
more precise than the rapid test
it is it's a fine balance between what's
reliable
and what's practical but the rapid tests
come with their challenges too
in germany they can only be administered
by a trained health worker
that costs time and money and means
people can't test themselves at home
nurse yves barman understands the
dilemma
as hospital staff of course we would
have liked to keep using the pcr tests
because they're more sensitive
but i understand that the labs are at
their limit and we need the pcrs more
urgently for the patients
when they arrive with symptoms then we
have to know fast but for sure whether
they really have coronavirus or not
bormann gets tested once every two weeks
enough to feel safe he says
but it's clear any hopes testing could
be rolled out on a broader scale will
have to wait
for many that means a test of patience
instead
now there are three key types of tests
being carried out on citizens
around the world at the moment the first
tests for a past infection is called an
antibody test or a
serological test a blood sample is
needed for this test it's then
analyzed on the existence of antibodies
these are produced by our bodies when
they face an infection
and can be detected once it's over
the other two tests look out for an
ongoing infection with sars
cov2 the first of these is the antigen
test it needs a sample of saliva or
throat tissue which can then be analyzed
for the proteins
that sit on the outside of the
coronavirus these tests can give results
quickly
but they're not as precise as
the pcr test for the pcr test
you also need saliva or throat tissue
but this time it's tested for the
viruses genome which is known as
rna the pcr test is the most
reliable one but in many cases
it needs more time to be analyzed
now i've been speaking to evangelist
kotzopoulos from
alm the association that represents over
200 accredited laboratories here in
germany
i asked him why when we have these more
accurate pcr tests
we still need another type of test for
covid19
the less accurate one you mean the
antigen test well it's a
it's a trade-off i guess between speed
and accuracy we have
multiple settings in patient care where
we cannot wait
five six seven or even 24 hours for a
test result
so take someone who is admitted to
hospital
in an emergency setting for example or
in aged care in an old people's home
someone is swapped because he develops a
high fever
overnight you need a response very very
fast
and in such settings it may be
acceptable
to work with a little bit less accuracy
and less sensitivity
and that's how these tests have been
designed as well so
tests also have a package insert like a
drug
like a prescription drug and it's very
clear that these tests have been
designed
to detect virus in people who are
symptomatic
and within a certain time window and
that also gives you the answer where
these tests are not extremely good at
the moment and that's in
broad-based screening where people are
generally asymptomatic
they look and feel healthy but where
they could still be infected
and with these people antigen and
especially the rapid tests do not have a
very high sensitivity and we recommend
that pcr testing should be done instead
we're increasingly seeing mass testing
programs being carried out in various
parts of the world is that an effective
way of actually defeating coronavirus is
it just telling you where it is
well it's it's a different quality of a
program it's not the
continuous permanent screening and track
and trace program we currently do abroad
based right around the country
however it has its purpose too it
basically shines a spotlight into a part
of the population
at a certain point in time and tells us
how many infected people might there be
the the trouble with that is a little
bit that antigen tests again
are used and if the prevalence in the
population of the disease is very low
like we have now seen in northern italy
over this past weekend the positive rate
there was below one percent
the risk of false positive and false
negative results is very very high
and we also see the problem that a
negative
result could give some false certainty
because people can infect or get
infected
pretty quickly after they had a test
taken
but with a negative result they might
feel safe
and everything's fine and they go back
doing what they like doing which is not
quite the case so
we have to be careful with these results
but it gives us
interesting statistics to see how many
people might be infected within a
certain population group
if you wanted to wipe out the virus with
this you would have to repeat it every
day
and you would have to repeat for the
entire population
and that's of course not yeah it's a big
enough feat getting those people tested
once isn't it
but antibody tests so testing whether
someone has had coronavirus
in the past why is that useful
particularly when
we don't know how long or even if that
does make you immune
well that's precisely the point so
and that's also why it's not being
applied very much at the moment so when
you know someone has had the infection
a person has tested positive through the
pcr test has perhaps even been admitted
to hospital it is interesting to track
the antibody developments there are
different types of antibodies which
build over time
some very quickly within hours when our
immune system ramps up to fight
an intruder let's say some only develop
over time and then stay
and so it's very interesting to measure
in
confirmed positive cases how long do
antibodies stay which type of antibodies
build over which period of time
but for the current fighting of the
pandemic this is not a very relevant
information we need to know
who is infected right now and who has to
be isolated and put into quarantine the
antibody test doesn't help us with that
evangelist kotsopoulos from alm thank
you so much for joining us on the card
19 special
thank you and now it's the part of the
program where you get to ask the
questions to our science correspondent
derek williams
if you're diagnosed with covid19 and are
recovering at home
what measures should you take to prevent
your family from catching it as well
the last thing you want to do if you
catch covet 19 is give it to your
friends or
family unfortunately that can prove
challenging
if you live in the same household on the
positive side the evidence we have so
far
indicates that after your symptoms
appear
with every day that passes you'll likely
grow less infectious
though it's still grinding its way
through studies at least
currently we think that maximum
infectiousness hits around the first day
that you show
symptoms if not before so if you tested
positive
after you developed symptoms and are now
convalescing at home
and the people around you have tested
negative
then the likelihood you'll infect them
should as a rule
drop by the day here's what authorities
recommend you do first no visitors of
course and both you and caregivers
should wear masks in any interactions
even if it's hard
stay as isolated as you possibly can
preferably in your own room
with a window that can remain open if
temperatures permit it
door closed try to only eat there
as well a dedicated set of silverware
and plates is a good idea
if you have the option in your home of
multiple bathrooms and toilets
then dedicate one to your use uh
limit contact with caregivers if at all
possible
they really shouldn't belong to a high
risk group
they'll need to disinfect regularly
leave any dirty laundry or bed linens
unwashed for as long as possible
and finally don't forget that caregivers
will also need to quarantine for as long
as health authorities require
even if that means long after your own
symptoms
have improved
[Music]
and you can submit a question for derek
through our youtube channel
we have just enough time to bring you
the latest development in the race to
get a coronavirus vaccine
ready for distribution scientists at
oxford university working alongside
pharmaceuticals firm astrazeneca say
trials show
that their vaccine candidate is 70
effective but that is thought to rise as
high as 90 percent
when one and a half doses are given that
is lower than the percentages given by
pfizer biontech
and moderna however the oxford vaccine
is cheaper to produce
and it's easier to store